Jeremy and Stanley my first question is
for you I apologize Zach we're g to make
this really awkward I love highlighting
the value of a strong number one on the
call sheet so can you each tell me
something about Zach not just as a lead
in the movie but also as a leader on set
that you really appreciated yeah for
sure I mean I and I've said it before
I'll continue saying like he is the
biggest cheerleader like supporter that
I think I ever experienced on a set um
he made it feel so kind of um uh safe uh
all the time and and yeah just like just
like a hype man like before the project
during the project afterwards like he's
just like um uh so supportive and and
really gave me and I think the rest of
us like a great deal of confidence going
through the process well I it takes so
much courage to go through you know uh
you know just becoming someone else and
and uh you know the wrestling
physicality it's it's it takes a lot
these guys were like like let me take a
moment to support you guys I'll give you
a chance I promise can I say yeah yeah
okay no I just want to say that like you
know coming from someone who was you
know not a big big name at all and and
and is my first like large scale
production you know the the openness and
and um I don't know you you just were
totally like allowed me to talk to you
and be open about every aspect I mean
you were you were asking me you were
asking me like a you know Zach Efron was
asking me like you know like what do you
think I should do here like what and I
was like I don't know I'm going to say
I'm going to try and give you advice
right now but you I know you don't need
it and but it was it was just really
beautiful how vulnerable you were and
and open about us especially you know
someone who's who was newer to this kind
of thing and I really appreciate that
thanks man well dude you have like a
tremendous Insight it was fun we would
when we were shooting the movie like you
know Stanley would even necessarily be
in a scene he would stay and watch and
like have like constructive cool stuff
to say like your perspective was really
valuable so it was fun to go out and get
fresh eyes on it you can only talk to
your director so much before he gets
kind I will say newer but you hold your
own opposite heavy weights exceptionally
well and I just have a very good feeling
there's going to be many more
opportunities like that coming up for
you uh Zach for you now I'll let you
give someone else a flowers here can you
give me an example of a time when a
scene partner in this movie gave you
just what you needed helped you crush a
tough scene and maybe access something
in your own character that you wouldn't
have been able to reach without them I
mean that happened that happened at
moments with with all these guys you
know and like there I can think of of so
many but um there was a unique moment
with uh Lily in over the course of
filming where we've we were so focused
kind of on the brothers stuff and and
our Dynamic um there was just this when
she came to set and kind of um we
started doing scenes with her she just
brought such like love and light to to
all of the scenes that it was very easy
to be transported in a way that I think
Kevin probably was with his Pam and um
it was so interesting when she came to
set it was like she she wasn't there for
the first couple weeks so it's just kind
of like like us like wrestling and
trying to figure stuff out and brothers
and then all of a sudden it was like I'd
never met like a a woman before I was
like the the energy like shift within
like yeah I felt everybody just like was
glued to her she was imaginate and in
the best way she made everything light
and fun she brought this I don't know
sense of um just joy and fun I knew I
could tell it was contagious for
everyone yeah everyone loved her and was
inspired by her acting I think ability
yeah the authority she has in that first
date scene and also the power of that
hug and your reaction shot is something
else yeah I was all was real man it was
real it was that was that's Lily man
she's just so so good I can talk about
this movie all day I'm not allowed to
they're kicking me out congratulations
seriously no
work